hello and welcome to deep dive the
podcast that delves into the minds of
entrepreneurs creators and other
inspiring people to uncover their
journeys towards finding joy and
fulfillment at work and in life my name
is ali and in each episode i chat to my
guests about the philosophies strategies
and tools that have helped them along
the path to living a life of happiness
and meaning my guest this week is shazad
younis founder and ceo of miz match if
you haven't already heard of mismatch
from their entertaining underground
campaigns it's the revolutionary dating
app that's transforming the way muslims
find love and marriage thought about
this and i was as a man and i thought
why are muslim men generally quite
useless at all this i'm being i'm
speaking very generally to cover all the
the politically correct community out
there but i'm very politically incorrect
at times in our conversation shazad
shares with me how he quit his job and
built the mismatch app from the ground
up what it takes to find the perfect
match and the problem with dating app
etiquette for muslims
all right welcome to the show thank you
thank you for being here thank you for
having me i have a question oh why are
you banned from hinge
how does that work you know what i think
it's because i was overtly doing
research on because i do research on all
these platforms i can see what they're
all up to et cetera et cetera so you've
got accounts on multiple dating apps on
many yes yeah yeah and most of them just
don't have they just have gibberish on
the account uh actually all of them do
um i think this one did i actually had
memes i had four memes as my as my
pictures on it okay but i think i kind
of if hindi has a selfie feature or not
i can't remember anyway somebody
obviously blocked me i emailed them
saying i was just testing it out i had
memes it clearly had memes on the
account and they just said no thanks so
they uh
so do you think they blocked you for the
memes or they could they blocked you
because they googled your name probably
i would go with the second one i think
they kind of knew who i was and thought
oh hold up no thank you bye so it's
interesting how many how many dating
apps are there oh there's too many
there's too many um you know what i'd
say there's probably
i don't know eight big ones
i mean you've got you've got the
mainstream ones and they're wearing them
in the more niche market but uh i just
think if you're in this space you need
to know what everyone's up to um because
each app will tackle something in a
different way okay um and it's always
it's just interesting you know
everyone's kind of learning from each
other okay and just scoping the space
out so what what would prompt you to
decide you know what i want to make i
want to build a company let me build an
app that caters to the muslim marriage
market
what was the story there you know i'll
tell you you know what and it's one of
those things when you look back it's
just many kind of accidents uh so you
know to give you a background people
don't realize muzz match is 10 years old
we actually celebrated our 10th 10-year
anniversary a couple weeks ago it
actually started off just as a random
side project so i was you know for those
who know don't know whatever
i was an investment banker one of those
um for about nine years and i think it
was 2011 just me and my team were just
you know my team were just giving me
grief about being single and obviously
i'm a muslim guy i'm a good muslim boy
and you know which they found hilarious
um
and i remember they were you know we're
just cracking jokes and you know we're
like different platforms for different
religions and must match was the muslim
one and i remember just thinking that
name is that name is really good so i
bought the domain and then just randomly
so you just randomly decided to come up
with yay
yeah yeah so exactly literally right so
people think it was a deep story but it
literally was bans to start off with and
uh
and then i remember thinking um you know
all my friends were all professional
muslims in in london and i remember
yeah
and they were all like um it's really
hard to find someone blah blah blah and
i just remember you know i've always
loved technology and and ita and all
that kind of stuff and uh i remember
thinking what's out there was really
terrible you know like the websites were
pretty crap um you know a lot of the
muslim ones were we were still asking
things like what's your body shape and
how much you earn you know that's where
we were at and i thought this is
terrible i can do better than this so
literally side project i just said what
was a must match website just had it
ticking along i think it had a couple of
thousand people
who used it we actually had a few a few
weddings but nothing crazy
and then it got to like 2013 2014
so after the financial crisis um and
just as the app store was really kind of
taking off i uh um and i remember
thinking hold up this should be an app
this shouldn't be a website um because
and then i remember checking google
analytics and seeing um you know eight
of our traffic was coming from mobile
and it just makes sense if i'm messaging
someone that's quite personal thing i'm
not going to go into my laptop log in
and then hey how are you doing you know
and then turn the laptop off it's kind
of got to be on my phone um so for me
it's just a no-brainer and it's one of
those things once it was in my head i
couldn't get it out and i thought this
has to be an app and i was convinced
that somebody else was about to do it
and it was really eating away i mean it
got about 2014 and i thought screw this
i need to do it so um i quit my job
uh everyone thought i was mad my parents
thought what the hell's this this guy's
having a quarter life crisis here i
think i was um but i quit my job and i
sat there at home i thought how do i
build apps um um and in six months i
don't know how i did it uh i built moz
match which was you know in native
android native ios in six months and the
back end and everything i was literally
just meeting my bedroom coding away and
it's the only app i've ever built
and thank god it was successful
it was quite a gamble
but yeah and then it kind of it's one of
those things once you
for me i quit my job so there was no
backup plan as such um you know and i i
i saved up to quit you know i always
knew that i didn't want a whole career
in banking it didn't really interest me
for me i i just i always knew i had to
have my own business um and it's kind of
like i said it was
if i look back it was many accidents you
know it was it was just us having bans
about
what how on earth shaz is ever going to
get married to you know the the name was
matched to me just setting up the
website because i thought what was out
there was terrible two
obviously you know apps really taking
off and then me just thinking hold up
this should just be an app and then to
me quit my job and then just going for
it okay so quite a journey so it sounds
like the the idea came from trying to
solve a problem and just yeah no doubt
and recognizing the problem of
getting married as a muslim is quite
hard yes uh and you in particular were
having that problem so in a way you were
scratching your own niche yeah um
i understood the problem
yeah so
you know because i mean if i look at it
now and i think who could do you know
not in an arrogant way but you know
maybe you have to believe it who can do
a better job than us and i'm like i
don't think anyone can because i
understand the problem i understand the
market understand tech i understand
business and hopefully i've done a heart
attention job of getting a team together
and all of those things i think you know
undoubtedly are your edge right it's
what you bring to a table that somebody
else couldn't do or didn't do beforehand
so that's the way i kind of look at it
and think about it um
which hopefully gets us to where we've
got to interesting so if i can if i can
take it back to that time because like a
lot of people who are kind of listening
or watching to this might be thinking
okay well
a there's sort of two places where i
find that beginners stumble number one
is i don't know what idea to go for and
number two is once i have an idea i
don't know how to execute on the idea
yeah and it sounds like you had the idea
of solving a problem that you had
personally do you have any other
thoughts on this whole thing of like how
do you come up with an idea you know
that's a hard one i think you know what
the big problem we have now is we're so
busy
you know i was talking about this on a
podcast yesterday um you know now more
than ever
our free time is like under assault
right
every ounce of free time that we have
um we've got so many reasons to waste it
netflix watching stuff uh watching tv
there's so much media and stuff to
consume that our free time is busy doing
stuff
and we don't intentionally just take the
time to think about stuff and think
about ideas right like with a piece of
paper in your room or whatever outside
um
and actually thinking about an idea like
consciously obviously some sometimes
ideas come randomly right you're going
for a walk in the shower whatever and
sometimes they are the best ideas but we
very rarely actually just sit down and
concentrate and think of you know what
i'm gonna find i'm gonna think about
five problems that i have and people
have asked me this before and i always
say think just like rather than just
thinking genetically focus on your own
life and because that's the stuff that
you'll relate to and understand
hopefully better than anyone else so
think about problems that you personally
face whether it's through work whether
it's in a personal situation whatever um
that you whether you have the answer or
not just identify a problem
and then once you've let's say you've
found five problems um i'm gonna make
this up imagine you uh really like uh
non-pasteurized milk a really random
idea it's super random but imagine
you're like passionate milk i hate all
the milk that gets sent but i'm not one
of these old person i'm not gonna do
this oat milk stuff but i really like
milk and i don't like what's out there
right that's the problem and maybe
you're maybe you have some weird
interest in milk right now this is
what's random running whatever but fine
right it's a problem then the next thing
i will be looking at is okay um uh
what's the alternative to what's out
there what kind of uh
let's say we maintain it has to be dairy
what dairy alternating i'm offending all
the vegan people who are watching this
but let's say what's all the dairy
alternatives and then you know obviously
there'll be some non-pasteurized version
all right who supplies non-pasteurized
uh milk right now is there any mechanism
for getting that right now probably not
maybe in london uh maybe not um do i
think there's enough people who want it
and actually there's a lot of i remember
watching some stuff about this a lot of
people who are convinced of the natural
effects of what's in non-pasteurized
milk right straight from the other
almost right and then if you say the
kids and stuff because they say there's
always good stuff that comes out of it i
know some whatever health stuff anyway
right
but just going down that whole road of
exploring all of that and maybe you've
come across something where you find out
actually there's a lot of people who are
really interested in this and the big
problem is there's no real good supply
and no one's really nailed strong
branding around non-pasteurized milk and
maybe your brand is straight from the
other
utterly ridiculous right so something
like that i just feel like um you know
and this is a it's a terrible example
but it's just more that journey of
something that i'm really interested in
something that maybe i'm passionate
about milk uh um
and something that you think that no one
is solving quite right um in the way
that you would solve it right now okay
and then how you explore all that and i
guess crucially it's that's not to say
no one is doing it at all yeah no
everyone is doing everything yeah yeah
yeah like people always think oh
someone's doing it what's the point yeah
but you know what um there's so i think
most businesses
undoubtedly are iterations on on others
they're truly
you know landmark companies that take
over the world are the ones that really
break out and invent something
completely new that didn't exist but
within reason if you actually dissect it
it's an iteration on it really is and
it's just a massive iteration right
rather than something incremental it's
this massive gap and then oh my god
where did this come from um so i do
think within reason everything's and
that's fine there's nothing wrong with
that um what you're trying to find or
trying to identify is um
your country what your contribution is
that you think will make this thing
successful okay you know so let's say
someone's got an idea they think okay
i've got this problem i
love freaking love pasteurized
unpasteurized milk yeah and there's no
easy way of getting it um at that point
it's like okay so this is a problem
and it sounds like for you
the the idea the idea for mismatch you
you then were able to execute on it by
all right then i'll just build a website
as a side project
but you're an investment banker it's
like it's an unusual skill set for an
investment banker to be able to just
build a website like how how did that
happen yeah good question and people
have asked me this as well so i there's
kind of a few principles that i had in
my mind at the time number one was
and it's weird because when i was
building it i never built it with the
intent that this would be a big company
and that would have a massive team
you're never thinking like that yeah you
have this weird you have this weird
feeling in your head that obviously
whatever you're working on you want it
to be successful but you actually don't
know what that means i didn't know what
that means i had no feeling of what
success meant and if i look
back success after one year is to me
looks very different to success after
five years six years or whatever we've
been doing it so um um i would say for
me i always knew that if i was
ultimately going to win a tech company i
had to be a techie i had to be an
engineering guy i had to be able to do
all this stuff okay because i felt it
would make me a better ceo so you're an
investment banker like where did the
idea of being a technical so i i've
always loved tech i mean my degree way
back when was computer science but then
my so which was i guess was the seed
right
um so i was never scared of coding but i
said for nine years i didn't really code
yeah i had a few side projects i
actually had a really interesting
project me and a friend
we set up it was called unicity and this
was early this is very early facebook
and you know not that everyone said i
invented facebook
but effectively what it was was an
academic social network yeah um and we
actually built it and it was kind of
interesting as an exercise because we
built it but then we just didn't stick
with it and it kind of just fell apart
you know we the execution in terms of
the marketing and getting in people's
hands and actually testing it and all
that we just never did and it just died
as a as a project um uh but where's you
know so let's say for me i always love
tech i always loved coding but i never
really did it for nine years but then
when i started this i thought have to i
had this thing in my head of what it was
going to be and i actually designed it
it's funny i designed the first version
of muzz match in microsoft word i know
wow yeah yeah it's incredible you know
the ability to create squares and stuff
it was all in word it was horrible but
that's you know i wasn't a designer as
such by designing word and then um
and then i just learned how to build
apps literally so my first app was the
ios one um and i i learned by doing i
just googled like how to build an app
yeah yeah yeah and i actually started
with the hardest thing first i remember
so i started with how do i um and it was
properly hard actually how do i build a
chat messaging
a chat basic chat app how do i build an
app where two people can chat real time
and it was going down a bunch of
libraries and software and you know we
use basically the heart of what whatsapp
is built on so some software called
ejabbed um uh which is an xmpp which is
a protocol at whatsapp use so that was
basically what i used because there were
tutorials where about whenever how you
can kind of do all this and that was
painful doing it but then i built that
and then built everything else around
that um so i went to the heart of what
the app was which was chatting and then
everything else um
and like i said i learned by doing i
didn't really so i remember doing one
uh basic tutorial of xcode which is the
software on ios to build apps i did that
one tutorial of how xcode works and how
you do all you know how to understand
the whole view controller model and all
that stuff and once i learned it i just
got stuck on uh and that was the way i
did it um
and it was weird it was it took me about
four months to build the ios app the
apple app
which was horrible because for those who
know is in objective c which is a
disgusting language it really is now
it's swift which is a way more friendly
but back then swift was new um it was
objective c hated it
nearly gave up because i was getting
really stuck on quite a few things doing
push notifications on ios my god you'll
lose
you'll lose a limb doing it but it's
horrible anyway so uh did that and it
took me about four months to do the ios
app and about one month to do the
android one so
i guess the benefit was the back end was
done the endpoint's done and android
weirdly just seemed to make a lot more
sense in terms of i actually found
android
as as difficult as it is because you've
got all these devices yeah i actually
think they've solved it in a really good
way um for how android works not to get
too technical in it but but anyway so
that took a month and then um yeah i
guess from start to end it was october i
sat down on my computer and said right
how on earth do i build apps and it was
april when we
actually i think was end of march
remember or something like that when we
released the ios app and do you think
your computer science background
particularly helped in the making of the
app or do you think any old person doing
a medicine degree no it's all the time
so my thinking is i mean i'm sure it
would have helped because maybe i wasn't
scared of code yeah and maybe i no doubt
i understood the basic
mechanics of coding objects or in terms
of languages all that kind of stuff
however i'm a big i'm i've always said
this we're at an age now where knowledge
is free and it's everywhere right like
you can learn anything on youtube right
or on the internet everything's free
which is amazing it like genuinely is i
know i i genuinely think anyone can do
anything obviously different people are
better at some stuff naturally but
i genuinely think you put your mind to
it and you put the effort in you can
learn it just as good as the next guy
you know and there's so many like code
coding academies where you go we
actually hired a guy who was a plasterer
and he learned how he's learnt himself
he was a junior guy who when he joined
us um he did a course i think um and how
to build android apps and he just wanted
to learn how to do apps because
obviously better income and better
lifestyle for him and his family and he
started learning it and you know he grew
really well you know and it was great
just seeing someone from a completely
different background end up on this road
so i i do think anyone can do it
i think the decision you need to make as
an individual is um an honest decision
of where is my time best spent you know
is my time genuinely best spent coding
this thing or
am i stronger with another guy who can
or a girl who can code this stuff
um
if i if i look back
i do see a benefit of
two really strong different minds early
on i do think i do think you can be
stronger you can
i think you can make a lot more progress
in a shorter
space of time which is a good thing um i
think for me i had this very clear idea
of what must match should be
i was very determined to be the first
app out there um and that was my kind of
plus i had normally coming in which is
always a great driver uh so i literally
were just focused on i want to build
this and i think i can do it and i just
did it okay um the kind of good thing
about if i look at the flip side as well
now you know in those early days
obviously i've built the app designed it
i did the back end i did the website i
did the customer support i was approving
profiles to the point where the customer
support and proof of profile was like
four hours of my day every day and i was
like this is killing me i need to hire
someone to do this um so relatively late
in hiring as such but the beauty is now
everyone i talk to in the company be it
in marketing being in in the community
management team be it on the engineering
i genuinely can help everyone out and i
have a good insight i'm not i'm not at
that point where i have no idea what
they're talking about and i'm just like
yeah whatever you go and do that because
i don't know what you're talking about
not at all like everywhere i'm able to
contribute uh
and hopefully i hope guide the company
in a bit in a better direction we're
gonna take a very quick break to
introduce our sponsor for this episode
and that is brilliant i've been using
brilliant for the last two plus years
they're a fantastic platform for
learning maths science and computer
science with engaging and interactive
online courses and the great thing about
brilliant is that they really teach
stuff from a very first principles based
approach it's almost like the way that
we were taught in places like oxford and
cambridge where you learn a concept and
then you apply the concept to an
interesting problem rather than just
being spoon-fed stuff like we initially
learned in school my favorite courses on
brilliant are the computer science ones
as some of you guys might know i was
torn between applying to medicine and
computer science i went for medicine in
the end but i always had an affinity to
computer science and taking the courses
on brilliant like their introduction to
algorithms and their introduction to
python really helped me get more of a
grasp of computer science than i've ever
had before it's also great for learning
how to code which is an incredibly
useful skill to have especially if you
want to start a business and i attribute
like 98 of my business success to the
fact that i learned how to code when i
was in secondary school so if you want
to check out the courses on math science
and computer science then head over to
brilliant.org forward slash deep dive
and the first 200 people to sign up with
that link will get 20 off of the annual
premium subscription so thank you
brilliant for sponsoring this episode um
so i mean
around this whole
everyone anyone can learn to code
it often seems just like too good to be
true right like it's it sounds like what
a lot of people say and i would broadly
agree with this is that basically anyone
could just go on the internet learn how
to code and within a few months to a
year yep become like a proficient enough
software engineer to get a ridiculously
high paying job at a tech company do you
think that's unbelievable genuinely
convinced okay i'm convinced because if
you look at it i mean look even in tech
there's so many new languages and new
frameworks coming out everyone's having
to relearn stuff right
obviously some people are better than
others no doubt but i think for the most
part at most tech companies you
anyone can learn the skills to do it i'm
convinced um and it's one of those roles
i think
where with experience with practice and
with just forcing yourself to do it
every day and to push yourself
in terms of coding or building something
or building something more adventurous
you can get to that kind of stage i'm
convinced and i think the problem is is
people so if i speak to if i recall all
the conversations i've had with people
who are like oh i'm not a coder i can't
code
and i'll have you tried no well how do
you know you don't can't code yeah until
you try and literally struggle
and like and genuinely struggle and
think you know what this is impossible
my brain is literally not wired this way
until you've gone through that process
i just think it's it's fluff you know
you don't know what you're talking about
um and i think you have to with anything
you have to force yourself to be
uncomfortable i remember when i was
doing the ios app
and and this was three months in and i
remember there was there was
one was push notifications that nearly
killed me and another one was a memory
leak it would be you would swipe about
five times and then the app would crash
and and i didn't know why and i spent
two weeks just trying to solve this and
two weeks on one single problem that's
preventing you making any progress is a
killer and i was very cl i remember very
close i was very close to just giving up
saying this is too hard like i'm not the
guy for this um objective c as the
languages if anyone is a horrible
language whereas now what's great is
languages have modernized you know swift
jaw you know java is not cutting whether
in android um these languages are way
more
programmer friendly so that even helps
you on that perspective so yeah
i think until you've done it and forced
yourself to be so uncomfortable
um don't assume you can't do it okay how
did you keep it fun for yourself in
those sort of five months while you
you've quit the job at an investment
banker you've lost your huge salary
you're like right i'm going to grind on
this app i'm not grinding on the web
good question how you know what it's
part of it genuinely is you've committed
so when you quit your job you tell
everyone i'm gonna fill this up i never
think you're an idiot if you quit four
months in i feel like you will be the
idea um i didn't want to quit i'm not a
quitter number one i think number two
i
there was enough in me to think there
was something here that could that could
be big but i didn't know what big meant
but i i thought there was something here
that's probably the second thing the
third thing is i thought that i would be
of anyone to do this i felt that i would
be best suited to solve this like if i
couldn't solve it i would i didn't know
who would
um
fifth i just thought timing was really
good and by timing i meant the app
stores being more popular and apps just
being more popular
apps in the dating sphere and for the
muslim market you know there wasn't
anyone could point to you know i
genuinely was looking at who's our
competition for this and i couldn't
point to anyone which is a great place
to be i remember thinking that i
remember thinking for the muslim world
you know be it muslims in the west and
then muslims in the muslim world for our
product all you know i kind of felt i
thought as a trader which is what i was
in my banking career which is when
you're picking a stock you sometimes you
when you're picking a stock you're
picking a company where
naturally things are going that way for
the company yeah so so it's to give muds
matches the example in this actually so
i remember thinking about it thinking
all right you know their apps are
obviously no doubt becoming more popular
so i felt that trend was only going to
continue let's say for the muslim market
i felt all right for the muslim market
muslims are going to the taboo around
finding someone online is only going to
lessen over time no doubt because it
can't get worse than what it was uh
number three in the muslim market their
ability to uh oh their smartphone um
devices and the quality of the
smartphones is only going to improve
the internet connectivity in a lot of
these muslim countries only going to
improve their ability to pay is only
going to improve and i thought all these
things
just kind of make sense to ride this
wave yeah um
so for me it felt like this was the
right place to persevere with that said
i do remember like you know launching
the app six months after launching the
app you're checking i was checking you
guys it's every day you know i'd like to
go to the bathroom check me like how
many people are on the app at any one
time and it's like two years like me
with my youtubers
what's my next milestone yeah and it's
like three people yeah great uh i think
it gets about 100 and still like great
and for ages it wasn't that it was a
couple of hundred and you're thinking
man i quit my job for this like this is
minor and you i remember there was a
point where i was like maybe maybe i
kind of fluff this up you know maybe
there wasn't
this this isn't as big a deal as i
thought it would be um but then i do
remember this random moment where
somebody literally emailed in saying oh
um
thank you must match i found my partner
i got married
i was like wow okay this works like for
real because there was a phase where
that was out it wasn't that busy i
wasn't really hearing about it from
anyone in terms of the community of what
was going on or you know there was zero
hype if you will
um and it was kind of a moment where i
thought okay like there is something
tangible in how this can change people's
lives um
it definitely gave me an impetus to just
carry on okay um it wasn't like a
yeah this is it let's carry on you know
it's gonna be huge now not at all it was
all right let's persevere with this and
then i'm progressively actually and i
remember it just did start growing a
kind of a healthy clip um and i think
you know that kind of combined with that
despite it being really difficult and it
was still you know for the first half
years it was just me
um doing it and i think we got to about
50 000 members by the end of that period
um but i was enjoying it on a personal
level okay like i was enjoying the
process of just being in control of my
day yeah i was working i was working
stupid hours uh 18 hour days i had no
life i had zero social life um i was i
don't think i was sleeping great either
but but i was enjoying it i was in it um
what what do you think about it that you
were what was it about it that you were
enjoying do you reckon uh the control
okay i i remember because i still
remember i still remember being told
this uh in my more sunny days um
where i was so i was a i was a vp vice
president weber and i was going i was up
for director executive director which is
the next level right hello yeah exactly
right so big boy territory and i
remember so i think at that time this
was just before the financial crisis i
think or just after i come on but um and
it was kind of a there was a you know
two years was like the minimum you could
get to director but generally it was
three and obviously me being me wanted
after two years i was like gunning for
that um and i didn't get after two years
and i was fuming i was like why like i
felt you know at the desk we were
performing i was doing really well
etcetera and i remember there you know i
remember being told you know like the
your problem basically shaz is you're
not professional enough sometimes which
i'm not uh and you don't respond well to
authority
that line stuck with me because i think
it's still true i don't i think
my own problem is and
me i'm sure there's a some dose of
arrogance in there and i'm me being
stubborn to some degree um
but unless i totally
utterly respect and feel that the person
who is leading me is all over this and
is super smart and that's the person i
look up to um unless i feel that 100
i'm always like what am i doing like
like
you know maybe in some areas i think i
can do better than this why am i not at
that level you know and it's an
impatience it's just a natural
impatience you know yeah um and part of
it was that and i think partly for me
it was that lack of control i hated
you know our banks there's a lot of
process there's a lot of that's the way
things are done these are the hoops you
have to jump through blo and i hate all
that i'm just like why you know why am i
not just judged on this which is more
black and white you know i deliver this
you give me that and it never was quite
like that and i hate that kind of stuff
whereas when you have your own business
if it doesn't fail if it doesn't succeed
that's not you yeah you know like you
you'll look back at yourself saying yeah
i cooked some corners here i didn't
really work hard enough if you're honest
with yourself sometimes you do you work
damn hard and it just doesn't work but
at least then you can honestly say you
know what i should genuinely 100 gave it
my all and it didn't work and that's so
be it you can accept that i think that
was my problem that i or that was the
one thing i really liked was i was in
total control and if this succeeded
fantastic if it failed it's on me got it
which is a nice driver
so it's now when i was sort of ten years
into the mismatch journey yeah how are
things going at the moment like what how
how big is the app like oh my god so the
boring stats are where i think we have
four and a half million members now
globally uh
over a hundred thousand successes people
around the world over a hundred thousand
yeah it's crazy success is in marriage
yeah yeah yeah really
it blows our minds
we have 300 people a day more than um
who leave the app yeah and and don't
come back and tell us thank you must
match i met my partner don't need you
anymore which is amazing and it blows
our mind we've got weddings everywhere i
think we've got members in the 190
countries i think north korea is one
country we don't have members in
i remember it's an odd it's an odd point
on
on the maps um uh yeah as a team we're
approaching 60 people now i think we've
hired like 25 people in the last year
alone um over locked down and over the
whole work from home um the colby
pandemic etc
for us
thankfully we've been hitting records um
so actually just last last week we uh
last saturday and last sunday were two
record days for us on nearly every
metric um part of that was after ramadan
all the muslims wake up and just get
back on the app right so we've been
crazy busy after amazon for sure so
they're part of that um
and just for us you know we've what
we're doing is clearly working which is
great um there's a lot more to do and i
think i'm i'm forever
impatient and frustrated you know i just
what do you mean by a lot more to do
like there's so much it doesn't happen
surely like message no it's
i have one one bit in me is always dying
to do stuff that's never been done
before to try stuff out to build stuff
that hasn't been done before and done it
at quality that hasn't been done before
particularly for the muslim market or or
main products i saw offered to them yeah
you kind of expect it to be like a ten
percent of the quality of like a product
obviously exactly and i'm like why oh
that's crap yeah like and i never wanted
that and for me i was always like this
is
this would never be acceptable for us
right um so for us the bar has to be
high you know and i always tell our team
our our customers all use
instagram snapchat they all use all
these other big apps and that's where
the bar is and if we're not there
they'll think we're crap yeah so for us
that's where they bought i know don't be
wrong i don't think we're quite there
but that's where we strive towards you
know where we've effectively rebuilt and
and this is one thing i'm never scared
about rebuilding the app yeah you know
we've we've rebuilt it three times now
and we're approaching our fourth which
and i would say this call it fourth
rebuild is probably the only one that's
been more of a genuine iteration whereas
the other three were way more of a
ripper plaster you know so
yeah exactly right well you know to give
an example august so we we launched the
app august april 2015.
august 2016 which was must match 2.0
we actually started again so it was a
brand new app and everyone had to we had
everyone started again from scratch
everyone had to create a new profile oh
wow it was a bit of a disaster because
everyone lost all their previous matches
but because all the changes that i had
because i spent my first year just
learning from everyone learning about
everything they hated everything that
they felt that we we lacked um all the
features that i thought were missing and
i remember i i put it all in a in a big
google sheets document it was about 8
000 bits of feedback and i went through
it and i categorized it all and i
thought which ones can we do which ones
will we never do which ones do i think
are really important sat there and
designed all of what what i thought
would be must match you point or not in
word this time yeah it was in a
it wasn't a pirate copy of balsamic if
you know what balsamic is yeah yeah
it was some kind of design software and
i just designed it and then built it um
and the changes were so drastic i
thought
this is easier just to start again um
rather than trying to somehow budge
everyone across and so we did um and
then the third one was more of a you we
call it ui 3.0 but it's more of a ui uh
revamp and then like i said now we're
working on the fourth one which for me i
think is
i think we're more finding our place of
what is muzz match you know what is our
brand how should we frame ourself uh and
where do we want to be longer term okay
you know how did you decide that you
know what we're just going to delete
everyone's daytime
okay surely that must have been a huge
it was someone's been like you know what
let's
redo youtube from the ground up we're
just going to delete everyone's channels
it was
like you know what and it was
interesting because we had to send a
message out
saying because people were kicking off
going oh my god my match disappeared
what have you guys done i had to quit my
profile again
and i was convinced at the time we just
hate the pain yeah like i i felt taking
the pain would let us move quicker than
trying to find some middle ground of
like importing profiles yeah because
then you have to import their profile
and somehow figure out how they could
edit the old data and the new data and
all that i thought screw that um i want
to move quick and i genuinely felt that
this new version is so much better that
when they see it yeah they will be less
offended by it you know imagine you did
all that and you're like well it was the
same as before what the hell you guys
have done like did you just lose the
database basically whereas here it was
like you do all that and you're like
whoa okay this is nice um and i felt
that change would justify
uh the pain that we had to inflict and
this was like 150 000 members by that
time i think so if i remember the
numbers right so it was a decent number
but but if i look at the chart thank god
we did it because we overcame that pain
and then
you know genuinely the app was more
sticky people liked it and i think we're
on boarding people better and i think
people just like the app a lot more okay
um can you share revenue numbers these
days
uh
no i can't i would love to i would say
um
we do well sorry let's say a few things
on it um
we do we do well we've doubled revenue
in the last year okay
i would say we as a platform we're up
there i think last year
if i remember we were we were in the top
in the uk just to give an example in the
uk we were
one of the top 10 i think we were number
seven if i am i can't really exact
ranking uh the top seven uh top seven uh
top sorry number seven in the top ten
app annie rankings by uh top grossing
dating apps in the uk and that's across
all dating apps tinder bumble hinge and
all that so
we're in the big boy league on that
perspective i still think we're small
don't get me wrong um but we've grown
nicely um i think for us everything we
make goes straight back into the product
like and the team and marketing and all
of that you know we're not remotely
cleaning anything out everything goes
straight back in you know we're
like despite our growth i still feel
like it's weird i have a feeling that
any day we could die yeah it's so
strange i genuinely feel it and i'm like
same same with like my youtube channel
of course the more it grows the more i'm
like okay this is a house of cards yeah
it's like it could come together exactly
and i have this in my head and it you
get sleepless nights you know uh i had
to wait like it was weird i was like
obviously recording this thing i was a
bit late to this thing because i was
i had some stuff on my mind i had to
talk to a team about about like how are
we going to work post colby in the
office and all this kind of stuff and
weirdly last night i got to pray as you
do and then i couldn't go back to sleep
one half hour in bed with all these
thoughts in my mind of how we can solve
this office problem and what's the best
way to and it's weird i just couldn't
sleep and i was out the hell you know
this is random but then compound that
with thoughts of i just hate what we're
doing in this particular area or i'm not
happy about this or what on earth are we
doing you know like i've you know
sometimes have weird thoughts like that
um i guess that it probably keeps me it
must annoy my team i'm sure it does um
yeah hopefully it just keeps us slightly
on edge i feel like i've read something
about this i think in one of paul
graham's essays or
some way like that where he's like
you know the problems never go away they
just change and they're kind of sexy
yeah so when you're starting out you're
like why is the memory thing not working
for five swipes and now you're like
how do i get 50 people into an office
literally but it's just like a different
problem
how do you do a good one-to-one yeah and
how do you i've learned so i'm i don't
think i don't think i'm remotely there
how to manage your team how to manage
different teams you know one of my early
on
um i
frustrate you know we had a very small
marketing team and i i'm sure i
frustrated them so much because i just
couldn't figure out how to make
marketing work right i'm like you know
what does that mean
i think for me it was more understanding
like i'm you know i'm a product see or
whatever i hate that title but whatever
i love product i love that you know i'm
very into you know even now we're
designing the new you know muzzle match
right and i'm so into every every bit of
the screen i'm not like you guys design
it show me and let's just run with it
not so i mean don't get me wrong they
design it and they show me stuff but i'm
very in the weeds we you know if i look
right now i spend more hours of my day
consciously because i want to
with the the ux team and with mobile
team just going through
every screen of the app that we're
trying to redo and we build and and just
our whole thought process and for me
this obviously is part of where we're
headed as a business but anyway because
hey i enjoy it and i get it and it makes
sense
marketing is a whole different beast
marketing is not engineering marketing
you can't necessarily just have a spec
and deliver it and that's that and it
does it
the whole creative angle the whole
you know
what is a deliverable and and and to be
creative in a good way should you
shouldn't you have a time a deadline
yeah i don't know i'll talk about this
now like uh you know they'd you know to
give you a really small example on this
uh we're we're filming an ad right now
and you know we don't they'd almost set
themselves a deadline of or deadline
because i wanted to deliver something
but oh we're going to film this next
week and paul and and which i get
because you know
i'm probably comfortable it does come
from me that i want us to deliver on
stuff etcetera etcetera but then i'm
like i feel like the idea of what we're
going to film we haven't nailed yet you
know to the standard or to the level
that we want and that's where we need to
get to and it's weird it messes with my
mind so i'm sure it messes with theirs
and we haven't figured it out no doubt
but
for me it was the appreciation of
understanding that all right the way you
manage marketing people is quite
different or creative is different it
should be different uh the way i was
managing it wasn't bringing out the best
of them was annoying them i'm sure was
driving them what did drive them up
um and even then we we effectively
rebuilt the marketing team totally you
know like uh i think they were
frustrated with me but fair enough right
we rebuilt it and then even as a team we
figured out how should we work how does
the creative team work differently from
the brand people differently from other
people so you had a famous like ad
campaign on the london underground yeah
what was the story behind that
yeah so the um was a whole bunch we
actually did four or five but it was all
mostly muslim puns uh puns of honor so
halal is it me you're looking for yeah
uh you know elena which the og um uh
halal from the other side famous adele
song you had me at halal uh jerry
maguire um there was another uh there
was one more halal and i can't we had
one which was we timed for
um just after the uh we formally uh i
think when we're leaving brexit and like
when the brexit vote happened et cetera
was um it's time to leave the single
market we did that one genie is really
good yeah yeah we had one more there's
one that's there's there's missing in
all this there was one more um i can't
know what it was now oh yeah halal me
and it was like this one it was a bit
but it was halal meat which was a steak
with a cupid's steak
yeah it's a bit risque yeah yeah yeah i
think i don't know that that one works
but anyway great ads went super viral we
had like celebrities comedians putting
on their socials really good um uh i i'm
gonna take the credit for those the
lines were all mine um um i always felt
that
if we're gonna do especially a tube
campaign yeah it's gonna be funny yeah
it's gotta be good and it's gonna be
really good yeah it can't just be
average because what's the point right
it's either really good that you get
noticed or forget it there's no point
doing it and it was weird because it was
a bit of a punt because
you know as a campaign you know did we
run it and suddenly get tons of
downloads no it didn't make a single
difference right but what it did do
genuinely is that intangible brand thing
it got it got the name out there like
people heard of must match exactly
i remember we were we were hiring you
know we were interviewing people
engineers etc i remember i'm i'm in you
know most of our team aren't muslim
right you know we've got a lot of
non-muslims in the team particularly on
the engineering side um and for them to
be remotely interested in working for an
app like ours i'm like it must take
something surely right you know to go
and tell your parents or your other half
yeah look at this muslim dating i think
i think what the hell yeah but they do
right and i'm asking like have you heard
of match before and so many of them said
oh yeah i remember the tube campaign and
i'm like okay
and it was hearing that from so many
people where i thought okay this thing
worked
it did cement the brand it made it legit
yeah uh which is good but i think that
we only got away with that because the
strength of the campaign itself um the
idea was good it was funny it was viral
yeah uh it's hard how much does it cost
to run a campaign on the underground so
the
at the time this was when did we run it
i think we ran it
we ran one over a couple of years but at
the time it's like 20 25 grand but it
depends what you go for that was from
memory every other carriage on the on
the underground okay
like a week no two weeks okay yeah so
two weeks um so to get on every other
couch so so to get a single ad on every
other carriage of the underground yeah
for two weeks around about 25 25. that
was then i don't know where it is now
the biggest complaint i i hear whenever
i mention mismatched people is that
guys on there are really creepy yeah to
what extent is this like a problem with
the guys there's a problem with the
dating industry there's a problem with
the app itself like i'm thinking what's
the deal yeah i think i'm still trying
to figure out where does the problem lie
is it us is it the community is it guys
so
i think my conclusion is guys are videos
um i think from everything i've seen and
if you look at you know forget most
match if you just look at the general
caller dating apps mainstream dating
apps we're between the lines their
biggest problem is the behavior of men
mostly really okay
okay i mean i mean what was the premise
of bumble it was yeah women not that it
was anti-men yeah really it was not
happy with the male dynamic the way men
behave the way men treat women talk to
women etc and their whole
branding was all around uh the female
perspective right um and it's
it's a great branding talking point
right and that's for them what sets it
apart if you look at the app itself i
would argue it's actually not massively
different to other apps in all honesty
my research showed me that but yeah it's
not massively different in all honesty
yeah but obviously
that's their uh usp to some degree
whether i and i presume when i'm reading
maybe men hate that feature that women
have to go first i don't know and i
quite like it it means the onus is not
on me so it's interesting right so we
we actually built women goals first in
mud match in 2016 i think it was
for about a week okay and mostly women
so we built it yeah most of them were
like i don't want to go first yeah i
have to message the guy he should
message me and we were like this
community is not ready for it so we got
rid of it after a week interesting yeah
yeah yeah so we tried it failed it and
and there was another app out there for
the muslim market that tried to do it i
think it's bit dead now but they tried
it and yeah because some things work so
it's a good another so some things work
great in principle but not in reality a
good example
i was today just reading about another
app mainstream app um which was saying
oh you know like uh the death of swiping
and all this kind of stuff and there
they had a either a feature or the
central part of the app was that the
more you talk to someone the more their
face unblurs and we were mentioned in
this article because we allow men and
women to blur their photos if they want
and control who can see it anyway so
that was their principle so the
principle is great you know you're
you're committed you start talking to
someone and obviously the more interest
you you're showing them the more you
talk the more effort you put in the more
rewarding that you'll see who they are
that's a good filtering mechanism surely
yeah now the problem is is the great in
principle reality the reality is within
reason we are time poor right the
reality is
you know if you're if you're single and
wanting to meet people let's say you go
down this road of talking to people
without knowing what they're about and
you can't deny that attraction it's
important of course it is you know we're
it's in our it's in our it's in our dna
right it's in our our basic human
instincts of we're we're attracted to
people uh and attraction is a valid
reason of why people get together right
so to deny that i think is is just isn't
sensible i think personally so anyway so
let's say you went down this road and
you were talking to five people in a row
and you invested this time and talked to
them and then each one you're like not
my cup of tea that was a waste of time
probably after a couple of hours you're
like this i don't this is just not
working for me yeah you know you know
the converse could be the the the effect
whether you you speak to five people all
amazing and you're attracted to great
right
maybe you're not fussy
you know but but whatever so i just
think sometimes some things work great
in principle and on reality um i forgot
why i was even talking about this but
anyway um to go back to your earlier
point
so
i think generally there is a problem
with how men particularly uh
the approach they have online in how
they talk to people i think there's a
certain ease in how you can talk to
someone yeah and because of the ease to
start a conversation the ease in how you
can end that conversation or not or
choose not to end it are you ghost okay
yeah and i think that's a this is just a
modern phenomenon now yeah of um you
know just now it's it's easier than ever
to build a connection with someone yeah
be on facebook and all the social
networks whatever you know a random
person that you've never ever met you
can message them and have a conversation
and then no one feels like they owe each
other anything yeah that doesn't count
there's no like social cost just
ignoring them exactly right and it's the
same here and i think you know
so i think while we're at this juncture
where this is relatively new that's why
it's difficult to deal with so i think
part of that no doubt there's a role of
platforms like ours to encourage good
behavior and deter by behavior and i
think one thing must match has always
tried to be about we're trying to bring
out the good get rid of the bad you know
so things like you know we were the
first app to automatically tend to a bad
language you know so if you're if you
swear at someone on the app it's
automatically censored yeah which other
apps didn't have which baffled me we
were the first app you know on a
religious perspective to allow you to
have a chaperone in just novel no one
else was doing that
yeah exactly right no one's doing it and
i remember thinking about it at the time
thinking this is a no-brainer like why
have we not got this i built it and
whatever um uh we were the first app on
the security side to have selfie
replication right um we were actually
the first app i believe to have an oath
that you agree to before you use it so
when you sign up to muzz match
um it literally there was a screen that
would come up before you chat to anyone
that would say bismillah which means in
the name of god and it would say
basically i promise to use the app
properly and if i don't i'll be blocked
and banned
uh and you have to accept it to continue
now of course i you know maybe nine
percent of people don't even read into
whatever right next but
just by having that sets the tone of
what isn't isn't acceptable on this
platform um and
it's interesting to see other apps begin
to introduce some form of oath some
agreement that you as a user
agree to um um which is which i found
interesting um
one thing by having that and unequally
we have you know when you match with
someone
we do something really simple and
trivial which is at the start of the
chat we just say keep it hello yeah um i
will have a funny line like god is
always watching yeah or keep it i'll
you know um uh
yeah like our team see what you're up to
whatever right we have it and
of course most people ignore it but
for me it was important that that was
always there because i wanted to make
sure that we set the tone yeah our job
is setting us all um and the flip side
of that equally is if something bad does
happen do we turn a blind eye to it or
do we take action and for us we firmly
take action yeah you know we get rid of
you know i even tell the team you know
we we've blocked 100 000 accounts which
is a lot wow okay but because we know
what is and isn't acceptable and what we
do and don't want on our platform so why
do do you have any kind of but sorry
just to finish the final point the
muslim man
yeah yeah
as a man and i thought why are amazing
men generally quite useless at all this
yeah i'm being i'm speaking very
generally to cover all the the political
community out there but i'm very
politically incorrect at times but
anyway how and why are men muslim men
generally quite useless i just think
part of it is
our upbringing right we're we're brought
up and maybe slightly less so now but
generally let's say my generation
whatever we're brought up generally in a
fairly segregated world right you didn't
really chill with girls you didn't
really
there wasn't that those social settings
weren't really there yeah and probably
your only interactions later on were
maybe at university but even then if i
look up you know me at university
generally i had a very male group you
know a female whatever right
so we're brought up like that and then
you are you know by told by your family
or under pressure to get mad and find
someone right you know and you're like
what the hell what do i know about women
right and then you meet someone you chat
to them you get married and you suddenly
live with some with with a girl right or
you live together you've never lived
with someone before or you've only ever
lived at home so you're navigating all
of this and for some people you're
living at home with this other person
right
how you know that's difficult and so you
undergo no training and i actually
looked it and i thought okay
if you look at the the you know the
western world the non-muslims right how
do they meet people and all that stuff
and they obviously you know from a young
relatively younger age wherever from
teenage years onwards they have
relationships you know all that kind of
they go through all of that they live
with people uh with people of the
opposite sex they do all of this stuff
and that's an education right
relationships that don't work out or
they are an education that's part of you
learning about you about how how how do
i deal with other people how do i deal
with other situations uh difficult
situations good the bad ugly right um
and that's how you evolve as a person
and i do think for as muslim guys and
girls but but you know let's see guys
this in this particular scenario don't
have that education so i think we're
we're slightly
socially illiterate in some ways and
we're playing catch-up and i think i
would genuinely
not to give them you know to give them
the benefit of the doubt i would put
some of it to that
as a reason um to be fair
i think that's that's entirely
reasonable we were i was on a road trip
to cornwall with the boys over the
weekend and we were talking about this
phenomenon of like why are muslim men
weird yeah and we were sort of trying to
come up with like pet theories around
this
um i think oh yeah a big part of it is
the the gender segregation stuff because
i think
like if i think back to my experience
coming to university
i wasn't drinking and that sort of
barred me from the 98 of the social
interaction that was happening at
university especially as a first year
which revolves around alcohol
then it's like okay cool there are these
societies like the islamic society
pakistan society and things
and
in the islamic society the first time i
had heard that like
talking to a girl is bad basically was
through the islamic society i was like
whoa okay
that's broke but like for most of the
people there who had been been brought
up in more like sort of surrounded by
the muslims and stuff that was just
normal of course i'm not going to be
friends with a girl that's just
ridiculous
how on earth can you possibly imagine
that you you'd even live with a girl
like you know what's what's going on
there and it in a way
gender sort of
free mixing so so stigmatized you know
some people say rightly or wrongly based
on like whatever the rules are but i
feel like that must have an impact on
the kind of development for sure um and
i feel like for me i feel thankful now
i've got i've got female friends and i
live with a girl who can point out be
like okay
yeah
you know in this context you're an idiot
the way you said that thing was not
sensitive because that person said like
oh my god girls are sensitive about
stuff yeah
yeah yeah for sure that's not a model
that i had and even like you know you
know personal level for me right it's an
education i say things i know i do i say
things where
in my head on remotely big or aren't
remotely major and then for the other
person it's massive right and especially
for both for women i'm sure i'm sure i
definitely have but but and that's an
education for me to be like okay
not everyone thinks this way or i need
to be sensitive to this or i need to be
more accustomed to this or attune to
this or whatever um and i do think
you're dead right you know you've got
the religious angle of the element of
remixing and all that kind of stuff
which i won't go into um but but i think
there's one thing that you know um i
think we as a community have failed
somewhat is and was much great example
of this actually
we
i i've often been asked did you have
loads of pushback when we launched muzz
match you know is this you know because
at the time remember mainstream dating
maps were quite they were quite taboo
right it was like a little bit you know
whatever and and they had a bad rep i
think that weapons improved over time
and it's become the norm um now
obviously whereas for us
just the fact that we weren't an app
dating gap for muslims was like whoa
haram is this right but then and you
know thankfully we've been super
successful yeah um
um and i think you know we've been
successful because the need was clearly
there and people said oh did you have a
lot of pushback and i remember thinking
i would and genuinely
i don't think we've had as big a
pushback as i thought we would by a
religious community or whatever and i
think a because um the need is clearly
there number one
but i think b because no one solved this
they haven't solved it yeah you know
they haven't figured out like there's a
big crisis in the muslim community of
how do you get the young muslims married
and how do they stay married right and
you can hark on about the old ways of
doing things but unless you come up with
something that works and that is
approachable for young people and talk
to them in a voice that works you're
wasting your time and i think until now
we have religious the religious
community haven't done this because it's
difficult and it's messy you know
talking about i would love for
mainstream religious elders and speakers
to talk about how to navigate online as
a muslim yeah you know
how they are
how would they know yeah but even for
them to just rightly uh and so we're
having to fill the gap here right we're
having to talk about these things of how
do you navigate online how do you deal
with red flags um how do you approach
someone online what should you even talk
about what is good and isn't good to
talk about online all this kind of stuff
which are gaps right um but yeah
but part of me thinks because this is
new yeah
you either try and figure out yourself
uh
you can't just be you can't just be
offended by it or give up because it's
hard yeah it's someone else to figure
out interesting so changing gear
slightly yes um you presumably have
access to like
zillions of data points around kind of
preferences men preferences women
preferences and so on do you have like a
list of
what are the things that a muslim girl
is looking for in a muslim guy asking
for a friend uh i thought it was a
doctor youtuber was the the top of the
list i thought no
profession i probably i would say
professional is the main one yeah i
would say it's probably the biggest one
um i don't want to say stroke income
um oh okay uh but income no doubt is
important okay uh and i've i've heard
that and i've seen it so whether you
imply that by profession yeah is part of
it
but i actually think part of it comes
down to actually there is there is a gap
between muslim men and muslim women i
think muslim women are
academically and professionally yeah way
ahead yeah almost in men definitely and
more serious and more wanting to get
more in like every single
yeah so we're playing catch up already
and they're like where's the guys who
are at our level and that's where we get
stuck and that's where they get stuck
with that frustration yeah and i don't
know how we solve that but without like
we're trying our best but
the least we can do is help them
identify the people who come at the
criteria but whatever so i think no
doubt they're trying to find people who
are
professional income for the record
me posing with the tesla
but
because like income signalling oh yeah
yeah
you know
you might go too far okay
but i would say
uh me posting a selfie with my
stethoscope at work it's like oh hello
that's not bad yeah stethoscope the dog
survives you know that's good um you
know uh the guitar scene again you know
certain demographics
like but it's a bit try hard like you
know music is hard
you know you've got all the baggage
associated with oh yeah any type of
signaling and you're
this morning i really want to find a
singing teacher that i can have two
lessons a week
who was that i was listening to have you
heard these songs by olivia rodrigo
recently i've heard the
driver's license yeah kind of went viral
so her album came out like two days ago
yeah i've been having listening to that
on repeat and she's just absolutely sick
at singing and i was like damn how did
you do that i was speaking to a
completely complete tangent i was
speaking to a youtuber friend of mine
who's a professional like musician and i
was like bloody hell how are you so good
at singing she was like well i've been
having singing lessons for 20 years wow
and i was like damn okay lessons do help
okay
i'm going to get lessons
anyway
okay so include questions i think
younger profession and not being weird
is the fully the final one how do girls
define weird so you know what i and i've
seen this because i have sometimes the
misfortune of actually reading must
match chats okay um particularly when
something gets reported yes um
uh
definitely there's a
there's an art to a conversation no
doubt right um there's an art to how to
hold a conversation how to
ask the right questions how do you know
just how to carry a conversation and i
think a lot of muslim men um i'm very
good at it okay you know it's very
either
and don't be wrong i actually think
muslim women to somebody as well but
sometimes it can be very tick boxy you
know because you're on you know you're
on a platform like cosmos but you're out
there to find the person you're going to
marry right and no doubt most likely you
have this criteria in your head yeah and
for some people they're straight on the
criteria
i'm looking
yeah it's like too much too soon right
like
you know if you look at it probably the
first thing you want to see is kind of
am i just interested in this person yeah
forget everything else are they just an
interesting person that i can talk to
and then you can
drip into the other bits right of oh
what do you do for a living and blah
blah all that kind of stuff um
i think that art of conversation is
definitely lacking um and i've heard
that a lot um
i would probably say and you know you
touched on it earlier which is generally
speaking muslim women are way more
serious and their intent is way stronger
than a lot of muslim men not all but a
lot of muslim men um so for them the
moment they find a muslim man where the
he's equally on that same wavelength of
being cool with the intent yeah you know
a muslim man saying oh i'm cool with if
you want to get family involved early
yeah no problem you know happy to talk
because it doesn't mean you're getting
getting married right but i'm happy to
talk to your mum or your dad whatever
fine
that's important to you cool yeah you
know um that like i think for a lot of
muslim women it's a clear marker the big
thing i've heard time and time again
especially by muslim women where things
haven't worked out is um he didn't want
to talk to his it took him three months
to tell his family about me
you know like things like that right i'm
like that's not that rogue in like the
white people dating yeah
whereas i'm like okay well there's you
know why why um because like i said
doesn't mean you're getting married but
at least it shows that i'm i'm serious
and this is what i'm looking for right
to to even remotely involve a family
member um
so i think i actually think
and the thing is which is good for
muslim men is because that bar is so
terrible
yeah i'm not even joking having a
remotely sensible profile with just
normal normal photos
being like eight buttons
but like normal photos yeah i mean it
just looked normal
just a sensible normal profile with
nothing too ott nothing too fancy and
just having a normal sensible
conversation yeah
that's you're in there you're only five
percent i'm telling you and people don't
realize that they really don't um um so
i think
for muslim man if you're off decent
you're you're you're in good's dead you
know yeah because like so you've got
hope
there was hope for you all right you
sort my profile out get rid of that all
the flexing yeah
because i was speaking to another friend
of mine who um
this this guy actually emailed me
because because often i'm joking like
joke i say joke off when i say my
youtube videos i'm single and looking
for a wife and so on joking joking so he
mod me being like like i've helped loads
of my mates you know get better with
women and yeah help you out as well
pitch um exactly
and
i kind of messaged
him the other day because i was asking
be like hey michael any any tips on how
you have an interesting conversation
with someone over thinking of like
change or something yeah yeah yeah and
he was like you don't need to be fancy
about it you can literally just be like
hey hey hey how's your day going yeah
and i was like my mind was blind yeah
what's true i thought i had to in the
first message you know you know be
quirky be witty be funny comment
something about the profile not comment
on a photo because that's weird come
another thing he was just like man just
say hey how's it going yeah yeah
so i'll start a conversation
because i'm telling you and he's right
the
to be normal sets you apart now
because so many people
think they have to be this thing or act
in a certain way which is which is
abnormal and i'm sure particularly for
women it must be tiring yeah like
getting that kind of interest
it's like whatever you know like
and i think it'll be refreshing i'm sure
i can't speak for women i'm not one but
i'm sure it was refreshing to find
someone just normal with a head screwed
on yeah who could have who can hold a
good conversation and you're right it
doesn't have to be like a lot of people
don't
you know asking about their day
it's kind of different to asking about
their day and actually being interested
in what they what in their response
right uh and then that going from there
to you know they're going to somewhere
so yeah there's you don't have any tick
box questions either you know like you
want to be genuinely profitable
[Laughter]
[Laughter]
do you have any uh thoughts on for
example a 23 year old muslim girl and a
23 year old muslim guy are in very
different places when it comes to intent
for marriage yeah do you have a
a theory on what is the ideal age gap to
get to you know
what age is the man to be at the same
level as like a 25 year old woman for
example
i think
this is hard
being being
very general in my opinion here i would
say
i think men did no doubt take longer
it is we take longer to cook
even if i just look back at myself i
think it was after about 27 28 where
even i felt that i had matured in some
way yeah people still say i'm not mature
by the way but anyway well i felt i'd
matured i think job-wise i was in a
better place yeah i felt like i'd
figured things out a little bit more of
life or whatever or even about me or
what i was doing um
and i think i was just a lot more
attuned to
you know not necessarily like to be in a
relationship but but this whole dynamic
of meeting someone and talking to them
and getting to know them this whole
thing whereas if i look at myself before
then i think i was very immature i
you're not consciously thinking about it
with a with a grown-up mentality i think
you're quite young then so i do think
what do you mean by growing up mentality
as in understanding the quali i say
understand the longer term consequences
of things that you say and do
okay um you have you don't remotely
think like that like everything is now
you just do stuff yeah which is kind of
good don't get me wrong because you know
it's fun whatever right but i do think
um
let's say at 23
and this is why i don't think it's a
firm rule because some people do grow
together right you know let's say two 23
year olds with a lot of patients grow up
together and you know it's like a
beautiful thing with two people and so
they've evolved together and they become
this amazing
either you know in the two individuals
or this amazing couple because of the
way they bounce off each other from from
then but then probably more often i
would say i don't know what statistics
are but more often i would say they
probably end up going like that right
because
they grow apart because they're like i
didn't whatever i was whatever reason i
thought i was with this person then is
not who i am now yeah you know and it's
your only evolution i do think
um now for for us
you know let's say in the west here
i do think it's like 28 ish where
job-wise education-wise your own
mental growth uh you're at a place where
you've more figured life out okay and
what you want out of life and and by
implication then what you want in a
partner okay i think you have a better
idea then whereas probably before
most likely if you were to be honest
about it the person you were with
were just kind of accident
you know you just i don't know if you
just happened to be by the union yeah
yeah but
this is why it's hard and this is why
you know so many dating guys have all
the science of we have scientific dating
and all this kind of stuff you know
we've got all this personality
we don't have it and i'm still
deep down a little bit cynical of it
because i'm genuinely convinced there is
no science of why two people will work
and don't work there isn't no one can
ever explain why this combination of
personalities work right and by the same
token
sometimes uh
you know the accident your friend right
uh that you end up getting with right it
can work really well because the premise
of you two getting on uh uh was there
was no god there was no pretence this
was it and you know there obviously was
something you liked about that person
which is why you got with them um and
you naturally kind of grow because
you're patient it's hard it is messy
yeah but that's why it's fascinating i
don't think for so many things i think
there isn't a rule as such there's
general advice or the general thoughts
um but there's i equally think there's
plenty of exceptions which
i guess keep it interesting yeah so i'd
love to have a clear answer i don't
think i have it but if i had to give you
the lazy answer i would say yeah for
guys no doubt i think it is a bit older
because i think we need time to to
mature
um another thing i'm curious about how
popular is the blurred photos feature
and like because because that's
interesting that was like a novel thing
when you guys introduced yeah yeah so
like what what's the stuff yeah yeah so
i think when i last checked something
like 20 of women um and
five percent of men okay it used to be a
female only feature and then we had um
um and then we had quite a few men
particularly in the community who were
let's say well known who wanted to be
private and i was like actually i can
understand even as a guy if you want to
be private and use the platform so
therefore um you should be able to have
it so anyway both genders can decide to
choose to blow their photos and then we
went on a whole new whole journey of how
do you unblur photos do you both um blur
when it matches can only once does does
the male photos on blur and then the
women can blow afterwards
we change about ten times and we i don't
think we fully in the end we resorted to
we just leave it to you guys you can
decide who wants to unblur when you can
blur it back again if you want and fine
yeah so we've been on we've been on this
whole journey of figuring out how to
unblur the photos once you've blurred it
right yeah but anyway we actually did we
actually did some uh analysis on what's
the effect of how yeah
yeah
i know you're itching at least give me
data yeah so we found statistically with
blurred photos let's say oh this is from
a female perspective because i think we
did it when only women had uh blood
photos but anyway statistically you were
more likely to get a match
with blurred photos oh yeah however you
were more likely to be unmatched
straight after
so because i think for men they would be
like she's blurred whatever i'll take
the punt and like her yeah
and therefore you like them back you
match whatever but then the moment i
guess he sees your photo
and he's like oh not my cup of tea he
didn't match uh so that's what we found
in the data um so we've generally
speaking you would say having blood
photos leads to poorer quality matches
yeah uh and not as good conversations so
we actually did a thing um
i think about six months ago where
we because the principle of having
blurred photos is great privacy and all
that but the practicality isn't because
you know like i said we are you know
we're visual creatures both men and
women right um and and you know to deny
that i think is is
is naive personally so what we did was
um we educated users better of all right
if you want blood photos this is the
effect you get poorer quality matches
you will get seen less et cetera et
cetera all these kind of things you know
the quality will be poorer for you um
and so we did all that and generally we
found it um
you know uh which is the intended effect
but fewer people decided to blow the
portal okay so i think now we've got it
down to like 15 or something interesting
i think at the peak it was 30 for memory
sorry so
uh
i feel like this is one of those very
inconvenient truths about life that
people are superficial yeah and looks
matter it looks better yeah so
the thing is yeah this is what i find
it's just not very woke to even talk
about the fact that it looks natural
but where is the whole like
you know so let's say you go on the
islamic perspective right yeah a woman
can be married for four things four
things
lineage wealth beauty
and uh religion yeah right beauty is one
yeah also
wealth and lineage are not
lord mountbatten but yeah you know it's
like um uh but but beauty is one right
for a reason and no doubt look uh basic
human instinct and what's in us in our
innate nature is both men and women
there is an element of attraction to the
opposite gender right and looks is one
there is an id there is an ideal of
beauty whether you like it or not right
and you know no doubt in the west that
the idea is programmed to some extent
but it's there
uh so you can't fight it yeah um
and no doubt and don't get me wrong in
this whole situation women get a hard
time because they're beating over the
head with this with this vision of
beauty and this standard that they're
having to be held to right so no doubt
the setup doesn't make it easy for them
right but
at the heart of it and you know we can't
deny that both for men and women looks
are so important and they are and
there's nothing wrong with it there's
nothing wrong with it at all and like i
said you know the apps out there that
try and
it was one thing we're trying to do
sorry to to slightly counter that so
let's say you've got blood photos
so imagine you've got a profile now and
our profiles are quite rich there's like
22 different data points on the profile
there's a lot that you can put on there
and we're actually adding more so our
goal is
you know how can we encourage people to
be slightly less superficial how can we
bring out your personality better on the
app in different ways you know be it
with voice be it with video etc so we've
got some cool stuff that we're looking
to build um quite soon
especially that will help the blurred
profiles but i should help everyone you
know how do i
how do i get someone attracted to me not
just based on a photo that's the heart
that's right
exactly and then the flip side let's say
more so for women is yeah how can you
know the the you know how can we help
them determine how serious the guy is
okay if we can answer those two
questions
well if any dating gap yeah
that's like gold and that is where we're
striving uh towards um
and it's hard this is really hard
because you're trying to tackle that in
a way that you can solve at scale yeah
that you can solve for men that's that
you can solve for women that you can
solve using technology
you know it's a complicated problem you
know some things like i said sound great
in principle
but trying to nail that in reality is
very difficult um but but we haven't
finished we've got a ton of stuff that
and that's what for me keeps me excited
like i've got so many ideas where now
thank god we've got a team where
our ideas we can actually build yeah
which is amazing it's such a great place
to be and that's what keeps me buzzing
you know generally how how does it feel
because like you know
100 000
weddings have happened because of the
app that's a lot like a lot you as an
individual are having a
needle-moving impact on
the birth rate
yeah
which for the muslims is already high
no you're right it is that that's gonna
be weird right you know what i tell you
the way the weirdest and satisfying most
satisfying thing i had was once i was on
the dlr the train for those who don't
know in in kind of it was on the train
and um the guy on the scene in front of
me was almost match and i just happened
to just like look over and i thought i
was like hold up
yeah and trust me that feeling i had was
like like that's when it hit me when i
was like wow like this is
it sounds weird but it's real yeah like
people use it in their own time and they
you know they're getting use out of it
getting value out of it
and definitely you know the number like
i remember once i was at this event and
this um she's like a matchmaker quite
well known in the community and she came
up to me and she was like um shaz you
know you're putting me out of business
here because like and she'll like the
wheel she's like the if i speak to all
my clients the
the biggest reason they're not using me
and
you know practically the biggest reason
that people are telling me they're
getting married is because match is
working and i was like great i was like
that's literally what we're here for you
know we're putting our business but but
i was like great um it's working and you
know the
yesterday somebody emailed me saying oh
you know you know it was a success story
and i said by the way my sister also
found someone on your app and my brother
also found something i know like bloody
hell the whole family
and it's really good you know yeah
it's it's amazing it genuinely is and
like our mission
uh you know and i was telling the team
our mission is transforming how muslims
meet and marry yeah that's our mission
globally as we want to do um you know
like we've definitely made
huge strides in the west for muslims in
the west
but now we're looking like to the muslim
world how are they going to evolve you
know because no doubt that young muslims
in the muslim world their perspective on
marriage their willingness to be
empowered to find out it's all changing
right and we want to be the platform to
help them on that journey right um we've
no doubt got tons of work to do on that
as well but but that's kind of where
that's what excites me you know that's
my mark on the world when all is said
and done i want you know muzz match to
be genuinely an app or a platform where
people look up to it saying
you know the the real world impact in
the community of what we did you know i
think that's major yeah mate that's
really cool um i feel like that's a good
place to end it because our lunch has
just arrived yes perfect and then you
can tell me about your thoughts against
mbas yeah we'll do that i'll fly because
i don't think it'll be
i can't wait
all right yeah thanks for coming on
anything anything you'd like to plug how
can people find you how can you people
learn more about that yeah yeah for now
mustmatch.com download the app it's
completely free on the app stores on
twitter now personally i am on twitter
she's adding this underscore how to
point out how do you feel about people
just getting in touch with you i always
yeah welcome it so if you've got let's
say you're you want to start a business
you want advice on anything i genuinely
welcome people to just just reach out i
always like when i was starting up i
struggled to find a mentor or someone to
actually talk to who would actually
there's a lot of people who talk but
there's a few people actually been there
done that and i really struggled so
i try and do my best to i guess share
any advice or knowledge or whatever i
can to help other people get through it
so if i can help reach out to you
amazing thanks for coming on yeah
fantastic yes thank you wicked great
yeah that's fun wicked love it